honestly any old random thing that you
can do to a piece of paper can become an
analogy for the fourth dimension of
space you could scrunch fold or stab a
two-dimensional world and then say what
if that was our three-dimensional World
being folded through the fourth
dimension well in this case we would
have a wormhole a shortcut between two
regions of space drawings of wormholes
that look like this are another happy
accident born out of the need for
Simplicity they are showing what a
wormhole would look like for 2D
creatures but not for us raise this up a
dimension and instead of circular holes
at the entry and exit for us they would
be spheres and instead of a
three-dimensional tube connecting them
for us it would be a four-dimensional
tube going in one end and out the other
might connect two regions of space but
these worlds might not even be connected
a worm hole could also connect two
different universes by bridging that
extra dimension